[Music]
foreign
number one
Walmart love
[Music]
I was in Walmart I was 14 years old and
I remember seeing a girl
she had a giant scar on her eye and I
had a very similar scar on my opposite
eye and I wanted to ask her so badly how
she got that scar
but I didn't ask that day and I thought
I never would but boy was I wrong five
years later I'm starting college and I
go to class
a girl walks in and you'll never believe
it it was that girl from Walmart so
after class I went up to her and I asked
how did you get that scar
and before she answered she said I
wanted to ask you the same question all
those years ago at Walmart 20 years
later we are married with three children
thank you